bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de check up votre
magazine santé bien-être
au sommaire ce mois ci une nouvelle
application smartphone lancé par
l'association hf prévention elle vous
permet de repérer facilement des
endroits où trouver des préservatifs ou
des lieux de dépistage
nous nous arrêterons ensuite sur une
médecine douce encore méconnu en france
la chromothérapie un thérapeute vient
d'ouvrir son cabinet à thoiry nous
l'avons compris et nous parlerons
également du cancer et des avancées en
matière de recherche de spécialistes ont
été récompensés pour leurs travaux
mais tout d'abord direction la commune
de trappes l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
parisien vient d'inaugurer sa nouvelle
extension ainsi que la rénovation de son
ancien bâtiment des travaux de près de
trois ans qui permettent notamment
d'améliorer sa capacité d'accueil
sébastien combes et jonathan vie de même
pour les images nous voici à trappes
dans les nouveaux locaux de l'hôpital
privé de l'ouest parisien
une extension de cinq mille mètres
carrés inauguré jeudi
cette extension elle était nécessaire
pour le développement notre
établissement puisque on était en manque
et de capacités et ça nous a permis
également de cette émission ça pour
moderniser notre plateau technique
cette extension c'est presque trois ans
de travaux et un investissement de près
de 30 millions d'euros
ici dans cette nouvelle unité de dialyse
on est passé à 24 postes au lieu de 15
auparavant et de nouveaux services se
sont développées une modernisation bien
accueillie par les médecins c'est
d'abord le confort pour les patients
qu'il faut mettre ça en premier avec
l'ergonomie pour les soignants c'est à
dire un lieu agréable
on est au motivé pour délivrer des soins
de bonne qualité pour échanger avec les
patients ça a été l'occasion de
renouveler des matériels de traitement
donc on a maintenant des générateurs de
dialyse d un traitement d'eau qui permet
de délivrer une dialyse d'une dune tout
à fait d'une excellente qualité ici dans
le service de réanimation polyvalente et
de surveillance continue on est passé
d'une capacité de huit à quinze lits
quant au plateau technique d'imagerie
médicale
il est maintenant regroupées sur un même
lieu comprenant deux scanners est
deuxième
le bloc obstétrical a lui aussi été
repensé avec notamment quatre salles de
naissance au lieu de trois auparavant
une structure nouvelle qui a également
permis de rénover les anciens locaux
existants en à rénover certains services
comme la médecine à l'accueil qui est
nouveau notre bloc opératoire était
totalement rénové et il ya eu également
des espaces de consultation cet hôpital
privé établissements de générale de
santé compte 430 salariés et 110
praticiens
et toujours dans le domaine de la santé
hospitalière la maison de retraite des
sols à guyancourt va elle aussi
connaître une extension
elle compte actuellement 78 lits est
content d'accueillir 28 nouveaux qui
seront réservés aux malades d'alzheimer
les travaux devraient démarrer en
septembre 2014 pour une durée d'environ
un an et demi
c'est une première dans le domaine de la
prévention contre le virus du sida une
nouvelle application smartphone vous
permet de géolocaliser les lieux de
vente de préservatifs et les centres de
dépistage les plus proches de chez vous
un service disponible dans toute la
france est lancée par l'association
évinoise hf prévention patrick ça a été
dit mais pour les images
c'est une première en france
hf prévention en collaboration avec le
laboratoire msd lance la première
application smartphone de
géolocalisation de préservatifs le
principe est simple une fois que vous
avez téléchargé gratuitement
l'application elle vous géolocalise et
vous trouve un point de vente de
préservatifs ou le lieu de dépistage le
plus proche de chez vous un service 2.0
totalement anonyme
l'idée vraiment c'est de rendre service
aux gens c'est d'être une application
santé publique
une application pour chacun c'est pas du
tout de collecter des informations
aucune information n'est collecter c'est
vraiment un souhait de notre part et les
gens donc pourront directement aller
trouvez donc des préservatifs qu'ils
soient gratuits ou payants
qu'ils soient en lieu fixe c'est à dire
des pharmacies des tabacs presse ou
centres commerciaux ou encore des
distributeurs dans la rue quelques
conseils pratiques pour bien utiliser le
préservatif sont également proposés
d'après marina carrère d'encausse
marraine de l'opération
ce nouveau service est indispensable
pour les jeunes mais pas seulement pour
eux je pense qu'il peut aussi être utile
pour des populations quarantenaire
cinquantenaire qui utilise beaucoup
maintenant aujourd'hui le smartphone qui
eux ne sont pas du tout forcément
habitués aux préservatifs qui ont
agrandi avec avec l'épidémie de sida et
qui parfois des mares des nouvelles des
nouvelles vis des nouvelles rencontres
un moyen moderne qui touchent donc tout
type de public
d'autant plus que la journaliste parle
aujourd'hui d'une véritable baisse de la
vigilance à l'égard du sida un
relâchement qui s'explique notamment par
le fait que le combat contre le virus
dure depuis 30 ans déjà
tout est allé très vite au début entre
le moment où les premiers cas sont
apparus le moment où on a découvert le
virus on a mis en place un test de
dépistage c'est allé très vite et donc
très vite en est il arrivé des
trithérapies on a très vite on s'est dit
bon voilà ça y est c'est terminé
et depuis on oublie il n'y a pas de
vaccin qui n'a pas de moyens il n'y a
pas de solution aujourd'hui qui permet
d'éviter ce virus à part des
comportements protéger 6000 à 7000 cas
de compter
nations sont encore détectés chaque
année d'après le président d'hachette
prévention lorsqu'on regarde les
chiffres sur les régions île de france
et nord pas de calais on pourrait même
parler de catastrophe sanitaire sur les
lieux de rencontres extérieures on est à
plus de 5% rendez vous compte plus de 5
% de personnes nouvellement séropositifs
on peut plus parler de cris d' allah
enfin un moment donné ça devient
compliqué c'est pour ça qu'on prend les
choses à bras le corps et consorts une
application qui est une implication
citoyenne tous les lieux proposés par
l'application permet également de
trouver des préservatifs féminins sauf
pour les distributeurs
l'application est disponible en
téléchargement gratuit sur les store et
sur le site www.troupefantasia.com
se soigner par la couleur c'est possible
grâce à la chromothérapie en france une
quinzaine d'experts proposent de cette
médecine douce qui permet de guérir de
nombreux maux du quotidien
rencontre avec l'une des spécialistes
qui a ouvert son cabinet at war et en
début d'année atteint d'une inflammation
à l'épaule
yannick seront régulièrement dans ce
nouveau cabinet à thoiry donc on va
retravailler sur sur votre épaule pour
l'attendre évite donc une petite
demi-heure à agir sur l'épaule se
soigner par la couleur c'est ce que
propose de stéphanie fort à travers des
séances de chromothérapie si nos yeux
voilés couleur il faut savoir que
celle-ci traverse également tout le
reste de notre corps chaque couleur a
une longueur d'onde différentes et peut
être alors utilisé pour influencer nos
cellules vivantes dans le bon sens donc
j'ai choisi la couleur en fonction de ce
que je veux faire sur le corps
je choisis mon point est ma couleur et
donc je change tout est géré par
l'ordinateur stress fatigue problèmes de
surpoids troubles du sommeil ou encore
douleurs articulaires la chromothérapie
peut guérir de nombreux problèmes du
quotidien pour soigner sa tendinite et
yannick combine son traitement
médicamenteux
avec ces séances de médecine douce au
bout dans mon sens quand même peut-être
une
chaleur qui arrive au niveau de la
sensible sinon y'a pas de il n'y a pas
de ressentis particulier sur le goût
mais mais comme je la regarde il ya une
sensation d'amélioration et de qui vient
assez rapidement après la séance après
cela stéphanie fort propose des lunettes
de relaxation entre 30 à 40 minutes
les programmes diffèrent d'un patient à
un autre en fonction des troubles à
traiter il ya plusieurs choses il ya la
lumière colorée
il ya la musique et il y a des voix donc
en fait les lames tous les trois
ensemble permettent de travailler
directement sur les neurones et donc de
relancer les le cerveau comme il devrait
fonctionner lors de la toute première
séance un test des couleurs est
nécessaire pour établir la carte
d'identité chromatique du patient c'est
grâce à cela que la chromothérapie tu
peut cerner si le souci est plus
physique ou émotionnel elle se base sur
des données bien précises ça c'est notre
cercle chromatique donc on travaille
avec 12 couleurs justes 12 et chaque
couleur est relié à un méridien et après
on sait parce que c'est de la médecine
chinoise qui ça exige depuis 5000 ans
que le méridien agit sur telle émotion
telle partie psychique est elle partie
du corps en france il ne serait pas plus
d'une quinzaine d'experts et depuis le
début de l'année stéphanie fort est la
seule à proposer des séances de ce type
dans les yvelines une école franco
suisse enseigne la chromothérapie depuis
30 ans déjà
pourtant cette pratique reste encore
assez méconnue sur notre territoire
les gens pour l'instant c'est vrai on
encore l'idée que
le médecin peut tout faire là maintenant
effectivement ils s'aperçoivent que
c'est pas le cas que certains
médicaments ne sont pas bons pour la
santé
donc il commence à s'orienter vers les
médecines douces en général maintenant
la chromothérapie comme effectivement on
est très peu à exercer ça reste quelque
chose qui qui est en découvertes
comptez environ 60 euros pour une séance
d'une heure
deux prix ont été décernés début juin un
par le conseil général
un autre par le comité des yvelines de
la ligue contre le cancer
ils ont été remis à des équipes de
chercheurs qui travaillent sur de
nouveaux modèles de traitement car en la
matière les avancées semblent bien réel
david charpentier pour les images
un vaccin contre le cancer un rêve peut
être demain une réalité c'est en tout
cas sur ce principe de vaccins que
travaille depuis 20 ans laurence
zitvogel elles ciblent notamment les
mélanomes les cancers du rein et de
l'ovaire permettent donc d'éduquer des
nouveaux lymphocytes qui vont
reconnaître les cellules tumorales de
façon spécifique
ces vaccins seraient ciblés éviterait
les effets secondaires des traitements
général prescrit dans le cadre des
cancers et permettrait une immunité à
jamais contre les cellules tumorales
chez un patient donné des travaux
aujourd'hui récompensé par un prix de
12500 euros décerné par la ligue contre
le cancer
un autre prix de 10000 euros cette
fois-ci remis par le conseil général a
salué alex duval pour ses travaux sur la
complexité de la tumeur cancéreuse
tumeur qui ne ressemble jamais à une
autre
essayer de démontrer qu'ils ont derrière
une pathologie tumorale comme par
exemple le cancer colorectal qui
aujourd'hui est traité de manière
standard chez tous les patients de la
même manière il ya en fait une maladie
excessivement complexe qui est
hétérogène avec des groupes de patients
qui ont des tumeurs particulière qui ont
des caractéristiques génétiques
particulières parce que vous savez que
le cancer est une maladie des gènes et
nous notre travail c'est d'identifier
des sous types de tumeurs le cancer du
côlon ses vingt mille nouveaux cas par
an et un tiers de cette humeur sont
héréditaires c'est dire donc que l'enjeu
est d'importance et dans le domaine de
la recherche tout va aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus vite en ce moment on
à beaucoup de changements dans notre
approche des maladies on a fait
énormément de gains sur la coopération
entre les différentes spécialités qui
déjà en elle-même améliore les résultats
mais la recherche continue à nous amener
de nouvelles propositions de nouvelles
pistes de travail
le prix yvelines de la ligue contre le
cancer est remis depuis 1974
le prix du conseil général 10 truites
depuis 28 ans un engagement qui commence
à porter ses fruits
ce numéro de chuck un peu touche à sa
fin avant de le quitter
voici quelques dates santé à retenir ce
jeudi 19 juin c'est la journée mondiale
de la drépanocytose une maladie
héréditaire
à cette occasion un stand d'information
sera installé dans le centre hospitalier
de poissy saint germain en laye le
vendredi 27 juin une collecte de sang
est organisée à versailles rendez-vous à
côté de l'hôtel de ville de 13h30 à
18h30
check up c'est terminé merci de votre
attention je vous donne rendez-vous dans
un mois
d'ici là porter vos gains